John said that he has no idea where
Colin is and that he has not seen him in
a year and a half he claims that you
won't tell him where Colin is we are
both court-ordered not to speak about
the care and custody of our children in
detail I've known all along where he is
but the world doesn't know and I'll
leave it at that
Colin Gosselin RIA merges on Kate Plus
eight team to come up first though he
didn't say much the twelve-year-old son
of John and Kate Gosselin appeared on
Tuesday night's episode of her family
game night a few months ago you revealed
that he is away seeking treatment for
educational and social challenges how
did you come to that decision it had to
be a really tough one it was not even
really a choice it was on the advice of
his doctors and it had to happen how's
he doing he's plotting along and we are
too but it definitely was necessary
hates X Jon Gosselin recently sat down
with ETS Jennifer perros revealing his
estrangement from his kids and claiming
he hasn't seen Colin in over a year and
a half have you picked up the phone and
tried calling her and saying where is
Colin where is our son Lance I mean I
asked but she doesn't tell me she
doesn't answer any of my texts unless
they pertain to custody
[Music]